gentlemen we need a commercial for this
new game Medal of Honor any ideas I made
a commercial all right old man let's see
it
okay here we go somewhere in the deep
jungles of Ohio
that's my curves I don't understand
maybe with a compass on a map play with
a gun in a sack play with Billy cause
he's fat it's war out there kids but
this wall is a dud it's all fun and
games to you with your battery-operated
dil-don't guns shooting at invisible
enemies while me and my friends got real
medals of honoring ww2 but now everyone
I love is dead come on kids it's Medal
of Honor the new game from Electronic
Arts so what did you think you didn't
even show the video game that was fake
and stupid gentlemen I think we can all
agree that that commercial sucked and
that we need occurs
you